hello and welcome to introduction to
generative AI my name is Dr Gwendolyn
Stripling and I am the artificial
intelligence technical curriculum
developer here at Google Cloud
in this course you learn to Define
generative AI explain how generative AI
Works describe generative AI model types
and describe generative AI applications
generative AI is a type of artificial
intelligence technology that can produce
various types of content including text
imagery audio and synthetic data but
what is artificial intelligence well
since we are going to explore generative
artificial intelligence let's provide a
bit of context so two very common
questions asked are what is artificial
intelligence and what is the difference
between Ai and machine learning
one way to think about it is that AI is
a discipline like like physics for
example AI is a branch of computer
science that deals with the creation of
intelligent agents which are systems
that can reason and learn and act
autonomously
essentially AI has to do with the theory
and methods to build machines that think
and act like humans
in this discipline we have machine
learning which is a subfield of AI it is
a program or system that trains a model
from input data the trained model can
make useful predictions from new or
never before seen data drawn from the
same one used to train the model
machine learning gives the computer the
ability to learn without explicit
programming
two of the most common classes of
machine learning models are unsupervised
and supervised ml models
the key difference between the two is
that with supervised models we have
labels
labeled data is data that comes with a
tag like a name a type or a number
unlabeled data is data that comes with
no tag
this graph is an example of the sort of
problem that a supervised model might
try to solve for example let's say you
are the owner of a restaurant you have
historical data of the bill amount and
how much different people tipped based
on order type whether it was picked up
or delivered in supervised learning the
the model learns from past examples to
predict future values in in this case
tips so here the model uses the total
bill amount to predict the future chip
amount based on whether an order was
picked up or delivered
this is an example of the sort of
problem that an unsupervised model might
try to solve
so here you want to look at tenure and
income and then group or cluster
employees to see whether someone is on
The Fast Track
unsupervised problems are all about
discovery about looking at the raw data
and seeing if it naturally falls into
groups
let's get a little deeper and show this
graphically as understanding these
concepts are the foundation for your
understanding of generative AI
in supervised learning testing data
values or X are input into the model the
model outputs a prediction and Compares
that prediction to the training data
used to train the model
if the predicted test data values and
actual training data values are far
apart that's called error and the model
tries to reduce this error until the
predicted and actual values are closer
together
this is a classic optimization problem
now that we've explored a difference
between artificial intelligence and
machine learning and supervised and
unsupervised learning let's briefly
explore where deep learning fits as a
subset of machine learning methods
while machine learning is a broad field
that encompasses many different
techniques
deep learning is a type of machine
learning that uses artificial neural
networks allowing them to process more
complex patterns than machine learning
artificial neural networks are inspired
by the human brain they are made up of
many interconnected nodes or neurons
that can learn to perform tasks by
processing data and making predictions
deep learning models typically have many
layers of neurons which allows them to
learn more complex patterns than
traditional machine learning models and
neural networks can use both label and
unlabeled data this is called
semi-supervised learning and
semi-supervised learning a neural
network is trained on a small movement
of labeled data and a large amount of
unlabeled data the label data helps the
neural network to learn the basic
concepts of the task
while the unlabeled data helps the
neural network to generalize to new
examples
now we finally get to where generative
AI fits into this AI discipline
gin AI is a subset of deep learning
which means it uses artificial neural
networks can process both labeled and
unlabeled data using supervised
unsupervised and semi-supervised methods
large language models are also a subset
of deep learning
deep learning models or machine learning
models in general can be divided into
two types
generative and discriminative
a discriminative model is a type of
model that is used to classify or
predict labels for data points
discriminative models are typically
trained on a data set of labeled data
points and they learn the relationship
between the features of the data points
and the labels
once a discriminative model is trained
it can be used to predict the label for
new data points a generative model
generates new data instances based on a
learned probability distribution of
existing data thus generative models
generate new content
take this example here the
discriminative model learns the
conditional probability distribution or
the probability of Y our output given X
our input that this is a dog and
classifies it as a dog and not a cat
the generative model learns The Joint
probability distribution or the
probability of X and Y N predicts the
conditional probability that this is a
dog and can then generate a picture of a
dog so to summarize generative models
can generate new data instances while
discriminative models discriminate
between different kinds of data
instances
the top image shows a traditional
machine learning model which attempts to
learn the relationship between the data
and the label or what you want to
predict the bottom image shows a
generative AI model which attempts to
learn patterns on content so that it can
generate new content
a good way to distinguish what is Jin Ai
and what is not is shown in this
illustration
it is not gen AI when the output or Y or
a label is a number or a class for
example spam or not spam or a
probability it is Gen AI when the output
is natural language like speech or text
an image or audio for example
visualizing this mathematically would
look like this if you haven't seen this
for a while the Y is equal to f of x
equation calculates the dependent output
of a process given different inputs
the y stands for the model output the F
embodies the function used in the
calculation and the X represents the
input or inputs used for the formula so
the model output is a function of all
the inputs if the Y is a number like
predicted sales
it is not gen AI if Y is a sentence like
Define sales it is generative as the
question would elicit a text response
the response would be based on all the
massive large data the model was already
trained on
to summarize at a high level the
traditional classical supervised and
unsupervised learning process takes
training code and label data to build a
model depending on the use case or
problem the model can give you a
prediction it can classify something or
cluster something we use this example to
show you how much more robust the gmai
process is
the Gemini process can take training
code label data and unlabel data of all
data types and build a foundation model
the foundation model can then generate
new content for example text code images
audio video
Etc
we've come a long way from traditional
programming to neural networks to
generative models in traditional
programming we used to have to hard code
the rules for distinguishing a cap the
type animal legs 4. here's two for yes
likes yarn and catnip in the wave of
neural networks we could give the
network pictures of cats and dogs and
ask is this a cat and it would predict a
cat
in the generative wave we as users can
generate our own content
whether it be text images audio video
etc for example models like Palm or
Pathways language model or Lambda
language model for dialogue applications
in just very very large data from the
multiple sources across the internet and
build foundational language models we
can use simply by asking a question
whether typing it into a prompt or
verbally talking into the prompt itself
so when you ask it what's a cat it can
give you everything it has learned about
a cat
now we come to our formal definition
what is generative AI
jinayi is a type of artificial
intelligence that creates new content
based on what it has learned from
existing content the process of learning
from existing content is called training
and results in the creation of a
statistical model when given a prompt
jnai uses the model to predict what an
expected response might be and this
generates new content essentially it
learns the underlying structure of the
data and can then generate new samples
that are similar to the data it was
trained on
has previously mentioned a generative
language model can take what it is
learned from the examples it's been
shown and create something entirely new
based on that information large language
models are one type of generative AI
since they generate novel combinations
of text in the form of natural sounding
language
a generative image model takes an image
as input and can output text another
image or video for example under the
output text you can get visual question
answering while under output image and
image completion is generated and under
output video animation is generated
a generative language model takes text
as input and can output more text and
image audio or decisions for example
under the output text question answering
is generated and under output image a
video is generated
we've stated that generative language
models learn about patterns in language
through training data then given some
text they predict what comes next thus
generative language models are pattern
matching systems they learn about
patterns based on the data you provide
here is an example
based on things it's learned from its
training data it offers predictions of
how to complete this sentence I'm making
a sandwich with peanut butter and jelly
here is the same example using Bard
which is trained on a massive amount of
Text data and is able to communicate and
generate human-like text in response to
a wide range of prompts and questions
here is another example the meaning of
life is
and Bart gives you a contextual answer
and then shows the highest probability
response
the power of generative AI comes from
the use of Transformers
Transformers produced a 2018 revolution
in natural language processing at a high
level a Transformer model consists of an
encoder and decoder the encoder encodes
the input sequence and passes it to the
decoder which learns how to decode the
representation for a relevant task
in Transformers hallucinations are words
or phrases that are generated by the
model that are often nonsensical or
grammatically incorrect
hallucinations can be caused by a number
of factors including
the model is not trained on enough data
or the model is trained on noisy or
dirty data
or the model is not given enough context
or the model is not given enough
constraints
hallucinations can be a problem for
Transformers because they can make the
output text difficult to understand they
can also make the model more likely to
generate incorrect or misleading
information
a prompt is a short piece of text that
is given to the large language model as
input
and it can be used to control the output
of the model in a variety of ways prompt
designing is the process of creating a
prompt that will generate the desired
output from a lower language model
as previously mentioned Jin AI depends a
lot on the training data that you have
fed into it and analyzes the patterns
and structures of the input data and
thus learns but with access to a
browser-based prompt you the user can
generate your own content
we've shown illustrations of the types
of input based upon data here are the
associated model types text to text
well texted text models take a natural
language input and produces a text
output these models are trained to learn
the mapping between a pair of text EG
for example translation from one
language to another
text to image text to image models are
trained on a large set of images each
captioned with a short text description
diffusion is one method used to achieve
this text to video and text to 3D
text to video models aim to generate a
video representation from text input the
input text can be anything from a single
sentence to a full script and the output
is a video that corresponds to the input
text similarly texted 3D models generate
three-dimensional objects that
correspond to a user's text description
for example this can be used in games or
other 3D worlds
text to task text to task models are
trained to perform a defined task or
action based on text input this task can
be a wide range of actions such as
answering a question
performing a search making a prediction
or taking some sort of action for
example a text to task model could be
trained to navigate a web UI or make
changes to a doc through the GUI a
foundation model is a large AI model
pre-trained on a vast quantity of data
designed to be adapted or fine-tuned to
a wide range of Downstream tasks such as
sentiment analysis
image captioning and object recognition
Foundation models have the potential to
revolutionize many Industries including
Healthcare finance and customer service
they can be used to detect fraud and
provide personalized customer support
vertex AI offers a model Garden that
includes Foundation models the language
Foundation models include Palm API for
chat and text the vision Foundation
models include stable diffusion which
has been shown to be effective at
generating high quality images from text
descriptions
let's say you have a use case where you
need to gather sentiments about how your
customers are feeling about your product
or service you can use the
classification task sentiment analysis
task model for just that purpose
and what if you needed to perform
occupancy analytics there is a task
model for your use case
shown here are gen AI applications
let's look at an example of code
generation
shown in the second block under code at
the top in this example I've input a
code file conversion problem
converting from python to Json I use bar
and I insert into the prompt box the
following I have a pandas data frame
with two columns one with the file name
and one with the hour in which it is
generated I'm trying to convert this
into a Json file in the format shown on
screen
Bart Returns the steps I need to do this
and the code snippet
and here my output is in a Json format
it gets better I happen to be using
Google's free browser-based Jupiter
notebook known as collab and I simply
export the python code to Google's
collab
to summarize barcode generation can help
you debug your lines of source code
explain your code to you line by line
craft SQL queries for your database
translate code from one language to
another and generate documentation and
tutorials for source code
generative AI Studio lets you quickly
explore and customize gnai models that
you can leverage in your applications on
Google Cloud generative AI Studio helps
developers create and deploy gen AI
models by providing a variety of tools
and resources that make it easy to get
started
for example there's a library of free
trained models there is a tool for
fine-tuning models there is a tool for
deploying models to production and there
is a community forum for developers to
share ideas and collaborate
generative AI app builder lets you
create gen AI apps without having to
write any code
gen AI app builder has a drag and drop
interface that makes it easy to design
and build apps it has a visual editor
that makes it easy to create and edit
app content it has a built-in search
engine that allows users to search for
information within the app and it has a
conversational AI engine that helps
users to interact with the app using
natural language
you can create your own digital
assistants custom search engines
knowledge bases training applications
and much more
Palm API lets you test and experiment
with Google's large language models and
gen AI tools to make prototyping quick
and more accessible developers can
integrate Palm API with maker suite and
use it to access the API using a
graphical user interface the suite
includes a number of different tools
such as a model training tool a model
deployment tool and a model monitoring
tool
the model training tool helps developers
train ml models on their data using
different algorithms the model
deployment tool helps developers deploy
ml models to production with a number of
different deployment options
the model monitoring tool helps
developers monitor the performance of
their ml models in production using a
dashboard and a number of different
metrics
thank you for watching our course
introduction to generative AI